Film Courage: I believe you’re a fan of
Walter White of Breaking Bad?
Nikolaj Coster-Waldau: Yes.
Most of us are.
Film Courage: Yes!
Were you thinking of his character when you
were preparing to play Jacob (“Money”)
in SHOT CALLER?
Nikolaj Coster-Waldau: No…I mean I love
Breaking Bad.
I was a huge fan.
There are definitely similarities.
I mean he is a regular guy suddenly turning
to crime.
I think there is a difference though.
Walter White made a choice.
Well of course Jacob makes choices but they
are pretty much forced on him so I think that
is a significant difference.
Film Courage: Let’s pretend we have a time
machine and we go back to 1993/1994.
Nikolaj Coster-Waldau: Okay.
Film Courage: The film NIGHTWATCH?
Nikolaj Coster-Waldau: Yes.
Film Courage: So let’s say we wrapped on
the film.
Did you have a Plan B just in case this crazy
acting thing didn’t work out?
Nikolaj Coster-Waldau: Oh, no!
Never had a Plan B for some reason…very
stupid.
I’ve always had a very (I guess) unrealistic
belief that it would work out but it did for
some reason.
Yeah…
Film Courage: Do you think that there was
a strategy to it, besides your talent?
Nikolaj Coster-Waldau: No…I wanted to…I
had a dream even when I did NIGHTWATCH, I
had already been accepted to a theater school
in England.
So I just finished four years of training
in Denmark and then I was going to do this
movie and then go to Bristol Old Vic (theatre
school), where Daniel Day-Lewis had gone (it
was very exciting).
I went there for two weeks and then I ran
away.
But I always wanted to act and I wanted to
travel the world (if I could).
So that was the plan.
Then I moved to London and then slowly but
surely I started getting work.
Film Courage: Now you’re in a similar boat
soon with Game of Thrones if it ends.
Does it put new pressure on you to find something
or you feel it’s almost like freedom?
Nikolaj Coster-Waldau: Well it’s not like
it just happened.
I mean I’ve been doing this for 25 years.
I’ve been working every year.
I haven’t had any downtime.
I mean to worry that you’re in something
that is successful that’s going to hurt
you.
That is the least of my worries.
It’s usually the other way around.
You do something and you worry that no one
will want to see it.
And I’ve been working every year doing Game
of Thrones and I hope that if I choose, I
would continue to be working.
Film Courage: Do you like the unknown?
The freedom of possibility?
Nikolaj Coster-Waldau: Yeah…I mean that’s
I guess the nature of being an actor unless
you are in a theater but usually most actors,
we are all freelance and it’s not so much
a question of liking it, it’s just the way
it is.
Film Courage: Thank you!
Nikolaj Coster-Waldau: Yes.
Thank you!